là c'est le premier portrait que j'ai
réalisé et que j'ai publié sur ma page
gk exotique c'est celui de cleveland un
humoriste guyanais car partager notre
notre post et nous a remis en suis
vraiment pour le travail qu'on a fait
donc ça nous a motivés à continuer à
toucher tout d'autres artistes
[Musique]
dessin me prend environ toute une
matinée sa dépendent du fort même si je
travaille sur le format a3 c'est un
format qui est très grand ça peut
répondre toute une journée à réaliser le
portrait est réalisé chaque détail si je
travaille sous des petits formats à 5 ça
peut me prendre toute une matinée
environ à la progression du portrait
jeux films du début donc du croquis
jusqu'au résultat final
la vidéo apporte un plus en fait au
portrait par rapport à la sonorisation
au niveau de la musique et c'est juste
un petit plus
lorsqu'on regarde une vidéo ça raconte
un certain plaisir au savoir comment le
portefeuille réalisés
[Musique]
un plaisir et un honneur particulier
d'autant que ce sont des camarades
d'école avec qui j'étais a autant
puisque arriver avec des z'arts et
il m'a contacté un jour en me disant
qu'ils faisaient montoir près il est
magnifique il est
les fins en fait c'est assez du gael sud
et les bosses et chimie ont sans le
souci du détail c'est magnifique
une très belle réalisation
[Musique]